- Чи легко завести собаку у ФРН?
- За які породи 600 євро податку?
- Навіщо окремі іспити для собаки та власника?
- Страхування, чипування, контрабанда
та неймовірні історії порятунку псів у серії "Німці та їхні собаки".
Друзі, всім привіт!
Знайомтесь - це Зуї та її друзі.
Загалом у Німеччині мешкає 10 мільйонів собак.
На вулицях ви не зустрінете бездомних псів.
Тож у цій серії пропоную подивитися поближче,
як живуть собаки та їхні власники  у ФРН.
Для початку завітаємо в гості до Катерини та Тобіаса в Дюссельдорфі.
Разом з господарями на порозі вже нетерпляче чекають їхні чихуахуа - Чарлі і Маруся.
Чарлі зацікавився камерою і переслідує мене по всій квартирі.
У цього допитливого собаки - цікава історія.
Ми забрали Чарлі з притулку в Москві, у Росії.
За допомогою моїх друзів його вдалося переправити до Німеччини.
Я би сказала, що більше половини собак тут власники забрали з притулків
або організацій з порятунку тварин, з німецьких  або із закордонних.
Видно, що Чарлі щасливий і купається в любові.
Схоже, пес вже забув ті часи, коли його без шерсті, вимореного голодом
від попередньої власниці забрали захисники тварин.
Потім був притулок. Саме там за допомогою друзів його і знайшла родина Куль.
Для того, щоб Чарлі зміг прилетіти в ЄС, йому зробили всі необхідні щеплення.
І ось тепер він - повністю легалізована німецька собака з реєстрацією у податковій
за місцем проживання, про що свідчить собачий жетон - німецькою "хундемарке".
Він завжди має бути на ошийнику.
Коли гуляєш надворі з собакою і тебе зупиняють
співробітники міського відомства правопорядку
вони мають право проконтролювати, чи зареєстрований собака,
чи сплачені за нього податки.
Тобіас, щоправда, зізнався, що поки їх жодного разу не зупиняли для перевірок.
У Дюссельдорфі річний податок на собаку, незалежно від її розміру - 96 євро.
Набагато вищі податки лише на окремий перелік небезпечних порід.
У кожній федеральній землі свої тарифи.
Виманюємо Марусю смаколиками з-під дивану і йдемо гуляти на вулицю.
Ось така несподівана дружба - крихітна чихухуа
і американський пітбультер'єр - собака бійцівської породи.
До речі, податок на собаку цієї породи зазвичай настільки високий,
що в любові власника навіть сумніватися не доводиться.
Податок на цей тип собаки великий. 600 євро на рік.
Однак Рафаелю вдалося переконати місцеву владу у тому,
що його собака попри породу не відноситься до небезпечних.
Для цього пес пройшов спеціальний тест на характер.
З'ясувалося, що Олівер, у якому тече кров американського стафордширського тер’єра
та  пітбультер’єра, врівноважений і дружелюбний.
Після тесту його власник тепер сплачує лише 96 євро на рік,
як і власники чихуахуа.
Також після тесту на характер Оліверу дозволено гуляти без намордника -
це неймовірна річ для цієї породи у ФРН.
Олівер - з притулку для тварин.
Ця порода заборонена для розведення,
однак брати цих тварин з притулку дозволено законом.
Для отримання дозволу на заведення такої породи  треба оформити страховку
на випадок пошкодження майна та можливого поранення людей.
Причому сума страхового покриття має стартувати від півмільйона євро.
Окрім цього Рафаелю довелося скласти іспит
для Сертифікату компетентності власника собаки.
Були питання на знання ветеринарії, анатомії та психології пса.
Також перевірили, чи вистачить у власника фізичних сил втримати Олівера.
І це ще не все…
Співробітники міського відомства правопорядку  відвідали моє житло.
Вони перевірили, чи є у мене сад, балкон або тераса.
А також з’ясовували, чи наявний ризик втечі собаки з квартири.
Для цього мене зобов’язали переробити ручки на дверях так,
щоб двері не відкрилися, якби собака підстрибнув і натиснув на них.
Закони щодо бійцівських порід у ФРН
значно пожорсткішали після трагедії, що сталася у 2000 році в Гамбурзі.
Тоді пітбуль забіг на шкільне подвір’я
і на ігровому майданчику  вбив 6-річного хлопчика.
А от і перевірка пітбуля на витримку і вихованість.
Олівер проявляє дружній характер і не ображає меншого французького бульдога.
Власник бульдога придбав пса у розпліднику. Бульдог - чипований.
У землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія чипування обов’язкове для собак,
які важчі 20 кілограмів або мають 40 сантиметрів у холці.
Мій пес міг би бути без чипа, для нього це не обов’язково.
Однак в нього є, бо це краще для собаки, якщо він загубиться.
На чипі під шкірою сканером можна зчитати інформацію про тварину і адресу власника.
Раніше розпізнавальну функцію виконувало нанесене на шкіру тварини тавро.
У ФРН існує кілька баз даних домашніх тварин,
до яких можна занести свого чипованого вихованця.
Для вільного пересування собаки в країнах Євросоюзу
за межами ФРН чипування є необхідністю.
Друзі, а тепер наша традиційна рубрика - не все в Німеччині  ідеально.
Ось це місце, де можна взяти пакетики для собачих екскрементів.
Однак, на жаль, у таких місцях як ось тут,
у лісосмугах на набережній Рейну в Бонні,
тобто подалі від центру і очей правоохоронців
можна легко вступити у щось слизьке.
Далеко не всі у ФРН  прибирають за своїми улюбленцями.
Хоча штраф, наприклад, у цій федеральній землі сягає 100 євро.
Наступна зупинка -  Занкт-Аугустін, що поблизу Бонна.
Приєднуємося до прогулянки з Йоне.
Хоча тут навколо приватні будинки, ліси та поля,
все одно собака гуляє на повідку.
У Німеччині повідок - обов’язковий.
Собака має завжди бути на повідку.
Виняток - спеціальні місця, де дозволено відпускати пса гуляти вільно.
У міських парках і заміських лісопосадках, в яких проживають дикі тварини,
відпускати собак заборонено.
За порушення - штрафи до кількох сотень євро.
Йоне відчуває грозу, що насувається і розвертається додому.
Псу пощастило: у його господарів велика ділянка, де можна бігати вільно.
Йоне зараз 10 років.
Він живе з нами з 6-місячного віку.
Ймовірно, він народився десь на вулицях Боснії.
Звідти його забрала організація із захисту тварин.
Потім опікунство над ним взяла одна жінка з Німеччини,
яка оплатила всі перші щеплення і обстеження для отримання твариною паспорту ЄС.
Потім пса  переправили в Угорщину.
Згодом родина Рудорф побачила фото цуценяти в інтернеті,
сплатила 350 євро, і його перевезли  у ФРН.
Все проходило офіційно через відому організацію захисту тварин.
На жаль, на схильності німців рятувати бездомних собак почали заробляти шахраї.
У Південно-Східній Європі багато бродячих псів,
їх відловлюють до притулків, і якщо тварин не забирають, їх вбивають.
Німці оплачують порятунок і транспортування до ФРН.
Це спричинило розквіт контрабанди.
Найбільше на німецькому нелегальному ринку собак з Румунії, Угорщини, Сербії та Болгарії.
Йоне навряд чи пам’ятає своє важке дитинство.
Зараз він вже дідусь і, щоб тренувати мозок, грає у спеціальні ігри -
відсуває потрібну кришку носом аби знайти смаколик.
Собаки у Німеччині, як бачимо, не лише друзі й розрада,
а й купа обов'язків і відповідальність.
Господарі повсякчас дбають про своїх улюбленців,
навіть якщо іноді доводиться розлучатися…
Район Бонна Мелєм,
і тут серед житлових будинків розташований собачий готель.
О, бачу під’їхали клієнти! Давайте з ними поговоримо!
Відколи ви користуєтеся послугами цього готелю?
З квітня. Ми суперщасливі і задоволені.
Собака тут знайшов собі купу друзів. Чудово!
Готель чи радше "дитсадок" для собак працює у робочі дні з сьомої ранку до сьомої вечора.
Раніше псів брали на цілодобовий пансіон, коли їхні власники їхали у відпустку.
Однак через скарги сусідів на гавкіт і виття на місяць серед ночі
від цієї послуги довелося відмовитися.
Закладом керують професійні тренерки собак.
Комусь може здатися, що ми тут просто граємося
і обіймаємося із собаками цілий день, однак це також велика відповідальність.
Загалом у нас є шість різних груп.
Собаки гуляють по черзі: наприклад, спочатку перша й друга групи виходять бігати у двір,
потім вони відпочивають у кімнатах, а наступні виходять.
Загалом готель може прийняти 27 собак.
Найскладніше, кажуть тренерки, - правильно вгадати характери
і розформувати всіх по групах, аби не було конфліктів.
Зазирнімо у кімнату групи 1-Б.
Все - як у готелі: ліжка з ковдрами.
Тут собаки мають відпочивати і спати.
Тут перебуває група, про яку ми точно знаємо, що вони ладять між собою,
коли всі разом в одній кімнаті.
Собаки відчувають любов і тим же відповідають вихователькам.
Ось так виглядає справжній собачий рай.
Однак до раю без щеплень не пускають.
Всі вони записані у паспорті собаки.
Це паспорт домашньої тварини у ЄС.
Цей документ важливий для поїздок за кордон.
А це інформація, яка міститься на чипі під шкірою собаки - персональний номер.
І далі йдуть щеплення.
У Німеччині вакцинації для собак не є обов’язковою.
Однак якщо ви плануєте їхати з псом за кордон, потрібне діюче щеплення від сказу.
Також для перебування собак у нашому готелі ветеринарна служба вимагає вакцинації.
На вихідних Анна-Ліза проводить тренування для собак та їхніх власників на природі.
А собачий готель на вихідних перетворюється на школу для собак.
Сьогодні в собачій школі - заняття для цуценят.
На них вони отримують найважливіші навички і знання на все життя.
Подолання перешкод, тримання рівноваги,
вміння пройти по вузькому містку,
йти на голос господаря навіть через вузький гнутий туннель.
Закріплення перших команд.
Ну і, звичайно ж, цуценячі ігри.
13-річний Аарон сяє від щастя, тренуючи свого цуцика.
Він 7 років вів перемовини з батьками щодо собаки.
Ти ж розумієш, що це велика відповідальність на багато років,
які думки з цього приводу?
Так, я, звісно, усвідомлюю, що поки ми не можемо далеко подорожувати.
Принаймні у перші роки.
Я маю тепер рано вставати.
Так, тепер буде багато обмежень на багато років вперед.
Я налаштовуюсь на довге життя цього пса.
Він піде від нас, коли мені буде десь вдвічі більше років ніж зараз
Я вже про все це подумав.
Вражаюча відповідь дитини!
Тож побажаємо Аарону наснаги,
а його песику щасливих років життя у родині.
Шановні глядачі відеоблогу "Відкривай Німеччину",
пишіть що ще вам цікаво знати про ФРН,
і я обов’язково про це розповім у наступній серії. Побачимось!